[Music]
in a surprise dick pic news submitted by
the guy with the hair oh that guy on his
boss air-dropping penis pics has become
the newest horrifying that subway trend
I always wanted to do that not the dick
pic
we did do that sometimes you want to
like airdrop and then all these other
people show up really what if I send
this picture to all 20 people yes I
almost did that yesterday I was at the
office and I was air dropping from my
laptop to my phone and every time I turn
on my air job I see ship's computer or
Joe's computer on airdrop mode and I
just want to send them random pictures
every time I see it we did that in
Europe so we were in a bus with like the
same people for like 10 days or whatever
so then when I would turn on my airdrop
same thing so we would just send
pictures of like monkeys with lipstick
random people like what the [ __ ] is this
but I'm kind of like damn this sucks
that this is being aired now because
then all the people that did are the
[ __ ] troll kids that didn't think
about this they're like that's what I'm
gonna start doing except though no yes
except keep said no she's saving a
picture stupid you saw it already yeah
you already see the previews up but then
you can decline it yeah you can't but
you still see it oh so even if you
decline it you already saw it not the
way these people are doing it so in New
York in the subway what's happening is
that strangers are sending people like
these notes so it says like oh so-and-so
is sending you a note and so this
particular woman Rita she's telling her
own experience how she was saying that
iPhone one would like to share a note
right that's what it popped up on her
phone and then she hit accept and then
you're stupid it ended up being a huge
close up of a penis and so she was just
saying that she was just horrified she
said that she felt like someone just
flashed her that's her fault for being
nosy though you know you don't know
iPhone one why you accept this [ __ ]
girl come on nothing good come from that
he's going to tell you by [ __ ]
deposited a million dollars in your bank
no excuse unless she's 80 and she
doesn't understand technology so with
airdrop you can literally drop any type
of files oh you could try yeah top
videos okay guys I was just making sure
that airdrop does the same let me ask
you though you had a perfectly fine
working phone why'd you have to change
it because each at your you [ __ ] it all
up with that green bubble you know what
next time with the group chat you can
just you can just do my iCloud that's
[ __ ] complicated you know just look
up Julia I don't wanna [ __ ] your
thing your specific you even see that
shape you don't open up your computer
it's only when you open up your
computer's open every day but it's too
late
what if you're trying to plan something
within five minutes yeah that's why
you're in the group we're all trying to
work things together Green bubble dude
bakes I appreciate it guys
and then my texts don't go through
sometimes what thing is that cuz the
green bubble the androids like messes it
up sometimes it's about Wi-Fi but I
don't have reception it's fine but the
green bubble I need reception for that
[ __ ] and if we're like if we're all like
out in Japan again and we're all on the
Wi-Fi we can't even text you cuz your
[ __ ] doesn't work like it's it's a group
we do and a whole another just for you
well you guys you guys are the greatest
friends because thank you thank you for
being so considerate including me in
everything I love hey you're the one
that decided to sign up with an Android
for your next frickin subscription
you're planning you know how many groups
the group chats that you have been
excluded for him because yeah
just kidding how many humming how much
longer you to a planet I think the one
more year okay cool then you can come
back no you know what when you let in
that green bubble soda without telling
us I was kind of offended me see why
would you do that you know what it felt
like it felt like every Friday we had
this group dinner that we always went to
and there was an unspoken law that every
Friday we go to that dinner but for some
[ __ ] reason you decided to go with
your other friends yeah that's how it
felt like without telling anybody that's
ditched us laughs Green bubble ass
forever it was forever was always blue
bubble like it was everything was right
in the world and one day I just send it
out and then you reply him the whole
[ __ ] thread was green I'm like I know
what happened that happened I didn't
think it was you at first I thought it
was someone else just to change your
number so if you guys don't know if you
have an iPhone you don't know about
airdrop there's a box where you can say
like receiving our airdrop right and you
can be giving off contact only or
everyone oh that's right because
sometimes people that you just met you
don't have their number but they you
guys take a picture and then they go oh
I'm gonna air drop it okay and then you
accept and then like you had to do that
everyone or else they don't know how to
airdrop you I'd rather just have
everyone on and then once it pops up I'm
like I don't know you decline you rather
see the dick first and gold no I mean
it's not like I haven't seen dick before
yeah but like stranger dick I mean I
don't know that it's really even from
them it could be a Google image so I
wouldn't be offended like it's not going
on my face or anything like it's just on
my phone and I'm like the client man
that was funny how do you how would you
feel that's because you like dicks flash
me in person in person like the
old-school way with the trenchcoat and
there's go and then they run away you
don't get offended cause you like God
yeah because it's not it so they're not
violating myspace that's not what you
said like months ago you say you don't
like flashers I don't know what the team
thank you for paying so much attention
to my life so you
action bad hard to frickin call out it
was like you clearly stated that you do
not want to have dick being flashed to
you and now you're totally cool with
that yeah in that scenario I'm like [ __ ]
like what do you do he's gone it
happened and you're just like oh [ __ ]
like that's kind of funny now cuz it's
like what can you do it it already
happened you saw it like what do I call
the car like you can't do anything you
don't feel violated I don't know if I
would feel violated I would just be like
what the [ __ ] cuz it's one of those
things if I'm assuming that it just
happens they go haha balance it's like
wait what the [ __ ] just happened
yeah you're actually gone so yeah and I
don't know how I would register it but I
think my first initial might be like oh
[ __ ] that [ __ ] just happened that's
[ __ ] crazy do you know what happened
and I think I would feel that way maybe
want to start settling in and be like
damn that's kind of [ __ ] up but in the
moment I'd probably laughs I'm like woah
what wait is that real life so that's
what I wanted to say I saw bum dick
recently that's gross
no you know we're in France oh no no
we're in Barcelona they had these like
huge tub trashcan looking kind of things
and apparently there was like a hole
where Kasey and I think it's like a
public urinal cuz it's not really close
but the reason why we think this cuz we
saw this man walk up to it he just whips
out his dick and starts peeing in that
little area thing we're like what the
[ __ ] and then so the way keeping I
received the person was dick so the way
we're he's giving the whole trash
camping was over here right yeah he's he
was sitting here I was sitting here so I
couldn't look at Casey and I could see
the man behind him and based off of the
angle I could see like his thing like
just right out there and there's such a
pervert who married at that point why
are you looking at
you know what I mean so then um yeah and
then I was like oh my god can we leave
cuz I kept seeing him cuz you know I
guess after you pee like you shake it
but this guy was like what [ __ ] and then
I can see him just staring down at it so
people got a shake one with another but
she was like doing this and I'm like I
don't know he was a bit hung no as I was
squeezing it out it's the last bit of
toothpaste you were with us when that
guy was peeing in the street we saw like
tonight violator looking on the street
of France yeah and he was pink toward
the street - what yeah like not like
toward a building like you know how most
public piers here they'll just pee on a
wall he's whipped his dick out and it
was like the the smallest tree it was
like this small it was like this skinny
yeah it was like a skinny little tree
but he was just pee if you was even like
using the tree to block him he went up
to the tree and peed like this yeah that
guy just peeing like in the middle of
the street maybe he was drunk yeah I
think so are we supposed to be like
taking back and offended by stuff like
that or no I feel I feel violated an
offender when I see it even though like
in that scenario I we just walked away
so I'm like okay I can move away from
this book I feel like if a flasher would
kind of come up to me today and just
flash and stake and then run away I feel
like I'd be like oh my god that was that
was traumatic irate yeah my eyes
flashing and peeing is different because
I feel kind of split about it because um
there's one side of me that's like wait
that's [ __ ] up you pretty much as I
rape me yeah like I wasn't ready for
that [ __ ] yeah but in the other side of
me I'm like we're all animals and we all
pee and [ __ ] and whatever like so it's
just flesh it's like someone going you
see what elbow I think it's really
intent behind it like they're trying
someone goes you see my forehead are you
gonna be like oh my god I wasn't ready
for that
you're not any inside like that there's
I'm kind of split like there's a side of
me I get it
I can see you know as society where we
are today it is affect us but there's
another side of me I'm like but should
we as a society let that affect us you
know my thinking is totally different
now now that I'm gonna
dad with a baby girl I don't want that
[ __ ] happen I don't want my baby girl to
see that stuff you know with Millennials
nowadays they all have phones whether my
daughter's gonna be 12 years old on the
subway gonna get an airdrop from this
guy's dick I don't want that [ __ ] I'm
gonna [ __ ] kill that [ __ ] oh
yeah that's nice thing in this article
as well because it's like it
it causes anger because you don't know
do nothing bad people that are
air-dropping to these bones they don't
know if it could be a child's phone and
they're receiving this [ __ ] car
getting really angry about this and I
probably never would have been like this
if I wasn't gonna have a baby girl do
you think right now before the baby girl
right it was like if I saw a big look
what I do nothing more on EP now that
you're gonna have a baby girl oh wait
what would have set someone says my baby
girl that but I don't want to have her
see that [ __ ] come on listen to you but
just the thought of it oh they said it
to me I'll PI show my daughter hey look
what happened
driving from Little Tokyo and then I was
like hey look at that homeless guy
jacking off yes yes yeah yeah yeah he
was just at the street corner and then
he was in he had his hand in his pocket
and he was going like this you're gonna
wheelchair too
yeah like he was just like was he stands
in a wheelchair
okay the wheelchair doing it Wow what
yeah what's this dude is he horny in the
street no I think he was just having fun
yeah boredom oh yes dude too relaxed
leader huff oh when he's anxious yeah
well there's all these people around him
two people standing next to him you just
well they're there in his house he's all
mystery but there is homeless friends
awesome oh they should know better then
I don't know I feel like if if someone
terrorizes me with their dick then I
feel like pretty pissed if I can't do
something equivalent and shocking to
them that make them feel uncomfortable
you would say something back to them
yeah yeah something to make them feel
like you know lie your mouth yeah and
then send them a note and be like hey I
like your dick meet me over here and
then that's what you'll be they're
perfect and you can't get in trouble
because you invited them and they took
that invitation yeah and he decided to
eat your [ __ ]
in front of you yes yeah I think that's
when the violated feel happens I like
that flashier feel it's almost like
someone runs up punches you in the face
and runs away that's what it's like
right it's like you two get to do
anything yeah [ __ ] you yeah hey guys
thanks for watching that last video make
sure to follow us on instagram @ JK
films to watch more videos right up
there
[Music]